I mentioned this the other night and I
it should be mentioned again it's been
reported that President Obama's
re-election campaign they're having a
little trouble the trouble is they can't
seem to come up with a slogan this time
around as effective as 2008 s change you
can believe in changing can believe in
was so amazing they just haven't been
able to find a new slogan and you can
tell from recent speeches that the
president's been trying out some new
slogans in front of audiences and he's
been getting mixed results the American
people understand is required to win the
future I laid out a blueprint for an
economy that is built to last
here in America we're laying off
teachers in droves settle for
second-rate roads
second-rate bridges and second-rate
airports take whatever you can from
every day about 300 of them you know
what really didn't work and we almost
have sent a great depression and maybe
we should try something
[Applause]
I go with Pittsburgh house bridges Obama
Oh 12s prefix